hi my name is Anthony McBride I've been
a screenwriter for about five years I've
been working on my current script for
about three months and I decided to
write it because it tells the truth
truthful and honest story about my
experience as a military intelligence
soldier in the United States Army and I
haven't quit on the script because it's
truthful it's honest and it tells a
story that shows the humanity of the
soldier in the modern day war and my
goal with it is to create a story that
riches to the masses and tells the story
that no one has heard of the story of
unsung heroes who have for Danis war but
have not saved the recognition that a
lot of the other soldiers in branches
had received one listener screenwriting
has taught me is that it is a commitment
and that it must come from the heart the
script is a commitment I'm committing
for as many years as it takes to create
the script when I write I write during
the night time typically after eight
o'clock p.m. when I watching a good
movie a movie that has some kind of
relevance to the script that I'm writing
and my screenwriting goals are to finish
at least six of my eight ideas for
screen screenplays by the end of the
year if I can and start selling my
script by mid-year or the end of the
year and one great story about my
screenwriting career is that one time I
was at UCLA Extension taking a script
analysis course and I was working with
this professor he was one of the
greatest professors anew and it turns
out I looked him up on IMDb and he
worked with CBS studios and he also
worked on a few movies a beautiful mind
and gladiator which really impressed me
and I sent out my first screenplay to
him in miraculously he said he loved it
and he was willing to work with me on it
and I have aspirations to work with the
morning pretty soon so that's it named
Anthony McBride north hollywood
california thumb courage